it's now time to welcome in on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line a super
bowl champion and the walter pate man of
the year what a weekend a couple of
weekends ago for our friend andrew
whitworth how you doing with
well good rich i appreciate having you
on man um so have you paid for a meal in
the last two weeks at all
a drink no have you i have not it's been
uh it's been hilarious you know as an
o-lineman you know we don't get a whole
lot of attention so uh i get to kind of
feel what it feels like to be a
quarterback for a week or two you know
it's kind of nice i like it uh you know
last time i saw you it was at the great
craig's restaurant here in los angeles
california i was celebrating coop's 11th
birthday you were celebrating your first
super bowl win kind of similar and um
you know except i didn't get a standing
ovation when i walked in the door you
did correct
that happened right that's right it was
uh that was pretty unbelievable we took
a bunch of the guys that we have a
dinner club with all throughout the
season that we always do and uh it was
really special for all of us to get in
there and just feel a little bit of love
from the city isn't that right i mean
that doesn't happen in la where you
stand up for the super bowl champions
that's as a matter of fact you know
hasn't happened since the raiders did it
back in the day here um
what's that been like for you walking
around town
walking wherever you know it's really
cool you think of how special it is to
win a super bowl and all the people that
are part of it but then when you start
just going around and you know grab a
cup of coffee or drop my kids off at
school or just any of those type things
and you realize how excited and happy
and just uh how much it's made other
people's day as well
um it really starts to sink in and what
a special accomplishment it is so many
people that it means so much too
uh it's it's just unbelievable so
rewarding just walking around realizing
man this is just good energy for our
entire city and area and everyone in la
just has a little bit of a little bit of
a you know standing a little taller a
little happier this week take me in the
huddle here uh andrew whitworth with six
minutes to go rubber meet and road um
last couple of offensive possessions
despite starting around midfield leading
to nothing running game not really
working at all and stafford gets in the
huddle with the rest of you and what
happened
in the super bowl
you know it was unbelievable you know
you kept having those feelings that uh
back to 18 and we we didn't play as well
as we wanted you know in that game and
even though we had a good first half and
this one um started to stall out there
and you kind of go back and remember
that in that game i felt like we got
kind of down on ourselves against the
patriots and worried about the fact that
we weren't having a good day rather than
just man just find one drive and go win
the game
and in this one i thought we were able
to really settle in and sean had a great
just called the offense overnight listen
regardless how anything's happened
you'll never regret just having the best
drive of your life right here and going
and scoring and finding a way to become
super bowl champs and
sure enough when we got in that huddle
you just felt that kind of calm and
resolved from our group that we were
just gonna find a way to meticulously
just move down the field
and keep moving the chains and find a
way to get in that end zone and to watch
it happen and be a part of it is just
something i'll never forget and what
goes through your mind andrew whitworth
when it's fourth and short and you're
going for it and this is it like this is
definitely go time you did have a few
all three timeouts left and it's
entirely possible the defense held and
you would have still had a chance to tie
not just win it with a touchdown
but the call comes in and it's it's it's
a handoff to cup
what happens uh do you go okay this is
it like what what do you got for me
there well you know you go through the
week and you have all these like hey
just in situational football we got a
couple calls that we may call and you
don't think of forcing a half a yard for
the uh chance to move on
and have a drive to win the super bowl
but that wasn't really the scenario we
worked but it was hey if we get third
and short we get a fourth and short
here's a call we kind of like to just
get that yard simulate a quarterback
sneak and actually hand it off to the
receiver and so
um you know matthew and coop did a great
job of executing it everybody kind of
sold the play the right way and uh once
you kind of felt this gift out when it
was like uh oh you know in in most most
of the time for us it's those
drives where we kind of find a way to
get a first down and we get in that
rhythm and sean's so good at just
calling it on the field after that just
never letting people huddle and keeping
us moving and so uh once we got that
first down we felt really good about our
opportunity to possibly drive this thing
down the field yeah and and the one
moment for me when i was watching it
andrew whitworth that i'm like okay this
drive could really be the game-winner um
despite the stalling that i'd seen over
the
entire quarter to that point was when
you did cross midfield that throwed a
cup over the middle and you got into
bengal bengals territory not on just the
edge but you were flat out right there
now um and then i saw two days later
that was a no-look throw by stafford
holy crap that might be one of the
greatest throws i've ever seen in the
super bowl in that moment in my entire
life did you did you know he threw that
no look until days later andrew i did
not until uh later that night he kind of
told me we were together but uh i didn't
actually see the video until the next
day or two and it's just you know it's
just those two guys man i mean i i i
consider myself somebody who gets to the
building pretty early in the mornings
and
all through the season you know rich
these two guys every day i get here six
o'clock to fifteen five forty five
whatever they're the first two cars in
the in the lot
they're together watching film watching
tape studying defenses thinking of how
they can kind of play off of each other
um to see those two execute that moment
i mean as cool as it is it's not
shocking and it's not something that
surprises me because the work they put
in together and the relationship they
really had from day one is uh you know
to me it's just a testament of
everything they've done and approved to
people man you put in the time and the
effort and the energy
good things will happen for you walter
payton manny of the year award winner
andrew whitworth and that was i mean the
super bowl the capper of a weekend in
which you win the award what a beautiful
speech
andrew beautiful speech that you
delivered
that night i don't know how you got
through it to be honest with you you
know how long uh how long did you get a
chance to work on that one
andrew you know really just going
through the super bowl weekend how much
time but we did have our tuesdays our
normal day off in the nfl and we kind of
scheduled our
our whole week to kind of simulate an
actual game week and make sure that it
was pretty normal so tuesday we were off
and
uh i went to our breakfast club that we
have every week and uh matthew and coop
and
when i left there i went home and sat
down at the house and just you know got
a laptop out and said you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna go ahead and just think
about this and say some things that i
want to put down so
i wrote it out and felt good about it my
wife helped me you know kind of i'm not
the greatest speaker in the world
probably so you know i got a louisiana
education but uh she helped me get my
words correct and uh it was great i went
out there and really didn't have to use
the proctor and just kind of spoke it
from the heart the same way i wrote it
down so it was uh it was awesome man it
was a really cool opportunity to get up
there in front of my peers first thing
first time i'd ever gotten a chance to
do that
in my career and just what a cool moment
that was something i'll also never
forget and what's it like to put on a
super bowl jersey
being the first time you get to wear
that patch too how about that what was
that like when you saw a real jersey
for that you know i think they they had
to push the league pretty hard to you
know usually you get to wear it the next
season
and uh just with them not knowing my
future or not and you know what's left
uh you know the league allowed it to
happen and i thought that was really
cool really special to me i couldn't be
more thankful for it
for my kids to get to see it for me to
get a chance to wear it
i kind of look like a nascar driver out
there
jersey but it's uh you know it was
awesome it was really special and really
cool and i actually got a cool moment
with matthew stafford's daughter
hunter who uh i picked her up after the
game and she sees the patch and kind of
grabs it that's a really cool photo of
me and her laughing at each other that's
pretty special yeah man you got the c
you got for your captain you got the
rams logo you got the super bowl logo
and you got that patch on your on your
jersey that was that's quite something
um so uh
the moment in the uh parade
where uh sean mcvay starts screaming run
it back at aaron donald and donald
basically agrees
does that mean that the the gang's gonna
come back together do you think
next year andrew what's your guess here
yeah i really i i hope so i mean we'll
see i mean everybody needs to make their
best decision for them but i really i
really hope so i mean i think that uh
aaron donald's just such a special
player and i thought
really this last half of this season
um he became not only a special player
and a great leader you know he's always
been by his actions i mean people can
follow him all day long by just
the silent actions of how he does things
every single day but this year i thought
he really developed his voice and his
ability to talk to the people he's
playing with and communicate with him
what he expects of them and what he
demands and
and i thought it really brought the
level of play around him to a whole new
level and
i think that that is a really special
trait to have in a human being like he
is and so man i would love to see him to
continue and love to see that defense
just elevate around him and and i think
it i think it really can he could be a
special leader in this league
well i mean did you see anything i mean
because again you know as you're at the
end of uh your road potentially
um and know what he does to get that
adonis body and to be as great as he is
and then we saw his greatness at the
most crucial moments
most crucial moments against arizona in
the playoffs against san francisco in
the nfc championship game against
cincinnati in the super bowl against
arizona in the regular season calling
game basically no who calls game like
he's an nba a three-point shot artist
you know what i mean no that doesn't
happen in the nfl but he does so
did you get any sense at all that he was
thinking this is this is a a grind that
i might be done with you get any sense
like that well i think anytime you got
people no different than really even
sean similar anytime you got people that
that really um they're excellent at what
they do but they also pour every ounce
of their soul into it i mean nobody
works harder than aaron donald nobody
trains harder nobody's for focused and
locked into every single thing they do
uh it'd be physically impossible and i
don't think there's a lot of people that
physically are able to train the way he
trains and and how hard he trains how
hard he pushes i know you know he's
already training right now just because
i know him well enough to know what he's
up to and i've seen him and he's already
training now and and he's just one of
those guys it's just rare so i think
when you start to think hey man
what else is there for me to accomplish
i've been a multiple time defensive mvp
i've now won a super bowl i'm a pro
bowler i'm all pro i mean i think you
can start to think how much more of this
can i put into the game and maybe that's
really where he was at but this this
little time right here where he gets to
step away and say what's really
important to me how much do i want to
submit my legacy in the nfl
um you know i hope he i hope he
continues i hope he continues to do it
because he's already probably one of the
best that's ever done it but i'd love
him to just stamp it and there's no
chance that anybody can say anything
other than aaron donald the greatest
defensive player that's ever played and
then what about you is it true that
gretzky uh and you had a chat andrew
whitworth is that a is that a a fact you
and gretzk well he was nice he was nice
enough to give me a holler uh after we
won the nfc championship and and
and really the super bowl week and after
um you know we we live close to each
other out here and they've played some
golf together so uh he's somebody i've
leaned on in the past just asking
questions about playing at an older age
and what what it was like for him and
those kind of things when he decided to
retire
and so you know he he just sent me a
funny just being funny he kind of said
hey man listen you know what's even
better than winning one is winning two
uh so
you know i i i get it he's he's he's a
great one for a reason so we'll see what
happens but uh my favorite part of the
whole conversation is he actually like
kind of was like hey man i'm sorry to
bother you i just want to communicate
i'm like you're the great one i would
never not answer the phone if you called
i mean i'll drop my kids on the ground
and pick up the phone
i get over it
you know hey the great one anyways but
no it's it's uh he's a great guy man
been a great reference for me and so i i
appreciate that uh that little nugget he
threw out there to kind of change my
mind a little bit if i am thinking about
stepping it down so when do you make
your decision what what is this a you
know because um what do you what's your
you know i think rich is one of those
things that you're probably what i mean
we're week and a half from the game
right now um i i'd love to probably take
another week or so
get myself a little closer to the new
league gear
and just get a little removed and say
how does the body feel what do i feel
like is is the next thing i want to
chase i'm somebody that regardless when
playing or not
uh i'm going to be chasing greatness in
something else so
i want to make sure that football is
exactly what i want to do i think it's a
discredit to your team and to your
teammates to not be giving your full 100
heart and effort into something you're
doing and so if there's a way i can help
them in this building outside a plane if
there's a way that i can be a part of
the game outside of playing or if it's
on the football field with them i want
to make sure that whatever i'm doing uh
i'm fully into and so i i want to make
that decision with a little bit of a
little bit of time away from the last
game and i'll do that the rams know that
and we're all on the same page so uh i
look forward to be able to sit down with
the family and the rams and make a
decision here soon okay
if i'd come up to you uh or somebody
come up to you uh at that table in combo
when uh when
it was dawned on everybody that
stafford's in town and
maybe maybe you know and then then he
winds up with the team that hey by the
way you're gonna not only win your
division but host the nfc championship
game and the super bowl and win all of
them what would you say
andrew
uh it uh i wouldn't told you you were
you know drinking too much tequila in
cabo i bet uh but
yeah i mean you know it's just
unbelievable it really is you look at it
it's crazy i remember we actually played
the niners on a year to the date of the
trade happening right and um i've
actually got a cool photo of me matthew
and sean taking a picture with cooper uh
we were sending him a picture of us
three together after the trade had gone
down um to just say hello to him and it
actually was around the exact same time
that michonne and matthew were hugging
right after the nfc championship
uh a year to the date
which is just unbelievable to think
about and
it's been quite a year as stafford said
it's been it's been kind of a wild 365
days
but uh it's been really special and one
i'll never forget congrats
i told you that when i saw you so well
deserved weddle too man i mean holy crap
what he did was insane
to go from the couch to two weeks later
61 snaps against the bucks you know and
then he's wearing the green dot during
the super bowl i mean that guy's in out
of his mind that guy is incredible what
he did tears his pack in the beginning
of the game and stays in for the whole
entire rest of the game crazy he said he
had the rest of his life right to
to uh to to nurse up his pec so bless
that guy and congrats to you congrats to
you and your your family andrew let's uh
stay in touch i appreciate it you got it
so much it's andrew whitworth everybody
walter payton man of the year award
winner hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here